Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, hast du noch einen Kater von der letzten Sendung?
Nicht nur davon.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 467 vom 3. September 2023.
Wir haben euch ganz schön im Regen stehen lassen in diesem Sommer,
gab nicht so viel Sendung, mit einer Ausnahme, mit der Sendung vom Camp,
genau, die ihr vorgefunden habt im Feed oder vielleicht auch auf Youtube da
was vorher zu finden, beziehungsweise, das stimmt ja gar nicht, auf media.ccc.de,
so sieht's aus.
Eine sehr zu empfehlende Sendung, wurde ich gestern noch drauf angesprochen.
Gestern noch?
Ja, von einem guten Freund und Hörer, den ich gestern Abend getroffen habe,
sagt er, auf dem Weg habe ich gehört, mit diesem Hessenfurter,
krasse Geschichte. Ich so, Hessenthaler.
Hessenthaler Grenzwurter, da kann man durcheinander kommen. Ja,
nee, das fand ich auch, war eine sehr angenehme Stimmung, wie das eben so ist,
in so einer Open-Air-Sommersituation.
Das war auch sehr nett bei Bits und Bäume, die uns da...
Schöne Bühne gehabt.
Genau, also auch vielen Dank nochmal an das Team, was da diesen ganzen Space
organisiert hat, der auch wohl gestaltet und so weit ich das mitbekommen konnte
auch wohl organisiert unterwegs war.
Ja, das war einfach schön und angenehm da. Genau.
Aber wir hatten leider einen Gast, der sehr gesprächig war. Zum Glück.
Ja, aber dann wurde ich ja die ganze Zeit mit dem von dir verordneten Getränk allein gelassen.
Du hast zweimal selber nachgegossen, du kannst jetzt nicht behaupten,
dass du mit dem Vodka Red Bull irgendwie Schwierigkeiten gehabt hättest.
Es ist einfach eine Sogwirkung, die da entsteht, da bin ich ja gar nicht schuld
dran. Sogwirkung? Ich bin doch Opfer, nicht Tisch.
Schluckreflex, Schluckreflex der dann einsetzt.
Keine Ahnung, die Intoxikation oder wie heißt das auf solchen Veranstaltungen
ist irgendwie schon Tradition vom neuen Podcasting.
Also da gab es glaube ich schon schlimmere Intoxikationen, die du dir jetzt auch aufkämpfen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wovon du redest.
Aber du hast ja noch Spenden eingenommen dann ne?
Ja das war, das fand ich spitze. Wir haben ja dann gesagt, hier,
wer möchte kein Bargeld.
Ihr seid ja schon so reich, dann könnt ihr doch mal das Geld.
Es war aber jetzt klar, dass der Julian gerade in der Situation ist,
dass er das potenziell eher gebrauchen kann.
Hat ja gesagt, dass er gerade sich beruflich neu orientieren muss und auch das
macht, aber natürlich dadurch eine finanzielle Durststrecke.
Hat und da sind 610 Euro zusammengekommen.
Warte mal, die war das nicht sogar mehr? Moment. Nee, doch 610.
Weil, also an dem Abend waren es 505, was ich beachtlich finde,
wenn da einfach so ein paar Leute mal eben 500 Euro zusammenkommen.
Und dann kam am nächsten Tag noch einer zu mir und und sagte,
ja, er hat seinen Camp Badge und zwar nicht das von 2023,
sondern das Cardio Badge von 2019 an Mais bietend versteigert und da sind nochmal
105 bei rumgekommen und die quasi die Kaufende oder der oder die Kaufende wussten auch,
dass das Geld dann an den Julian Hessenthaler geht.
Insofern haben die jetzt nicht so gelitten, sich hochzubieten.
Dann hat er noch seinen Badge-Verkauf für Julian,
was ich schon sehr geil finde,
weil ich würde mich niemals, würde ich ein Camp-Badge abgeben, ja,
also die, selbst wenn die, wie er sagte auch,
habe ich jetzt zwei Jahre nicht benutzt, hat er, stimmt auch,
ja, ich mein's auch nicht,
aber ich würde es nicht abgeben, umso cooler fand ich diese,
ja, Aktion, halt, sich da so zu überlegen,
ich, ich, ich hab hier was, was ich nicht brauche, was anderen Leuten potenziell
viel Geld wert ist, ist und das versteigere ich und dann fahre ich am nächsten
Tag da hin und gebe dem Linus das Geld für den Julian.
War schon ganz in Ordnung, fand ich eine sehr coole Aktion.
Auf jeden Fall. Warum würdest du deine Badges nicht abgeben,
sollen die dann auf Ewigkeiten in der Schublade?
Ja, die werden einmal im Jahr rausgeholt, dann gucke ich,
ob die alle funktionieren und ob die Jankett noch fliegt und dann werden die
Akkus einmal geprüft, dass die ungefähr bei 80% geladen sind und dann wird der Akku getrennt.
Ja, da hab ich meine Batch-Kiste, ja, und äh, dann...
Irgendwann werden alle zusammenladen, das ist wirklich so.
Ja ich kaufe auch bei jedem CCC Event, wo ich bin, das Textil,
auch wenn das sagen wir mal mir nicht gefallen würde, würde ich das tun.
Auch vielleicht, wenn es gibt ja manchmal Situationen, dass es kein schwarzes
Textil gibt und ich trage ja nur schwarz, aber kaufe ich dann auch.
Da gibt es auch einen riesigen Schrank mit Nerd-Shirts, die mir vielleicht gar nicht mehr passen.
Wobei nein, ich hab ja nicht zugenommen, Quatsch, die liegen so locker auf alle jetzt,
die hab ich zu heiß gewaschen und, ne sowas,
ne mach ich, aber ja, coole Aktion sich davon zu trennen,
Das ich fand das beeindruckend für eine
spontan geht mal werfen ein bisschen geld zusammen fand ich das eine
Eine coole summe wird ihn jetzt nicht wird er
sich jetzt nicht mit zur ruhe setzen können aber coole
hat mich Also fand
ich erfreulich hoch Für ein paar hundert leute mal eben kurz ohne ohne großartige
planung und so wir werden sicherlich auch wenn weitere pläne von julian sich
materialisieren die finanziell Spenden annehmen können, werden wir sicherlich
auch hier drauf hinweisen.
Genau, er hat ja auch einige Pläne verkündet, in dem Podcast müssen wir das
nicht alles wiederholen, falls ihr das noch nicht gehört habt,
hört mal rein, es ist wirklich eine sehr unterhaltsame Sendung geworden,
wir waren da sehr glücklich und zufrieden damit.
Ja, vielen Dank auch nochmal an Julian, dass er das mit uns gemacht hat.
Du hast noch einen Vortrag bei Bits und Bäume gehalten, ne? Du warst da quasi
so Stammgast auf der Stage.
Das ist meine Hood.
Ja naja, ich hab dann wahrscheinlich so den letzten Vortrag auf dem ganzen Camp
gehalten oder zumindest einen der letzten Vorträge und hab halt nochmal einen
Rückblick auf die ganze Projekt Blinkenlights Zeit geliefert,
einiges erzählt, was ich vielleicht auch schon früher mal erzählt habe,
aber vielleicht nicht so vollumfänglich.
Auch mal ein paar Sachen gezeigt, die wir alle so vorhatten und die dann nicht
geklappt haben. Als ich durch mein Material gegangen bin, habe ich gemerkt,
oh Gott, das ist so lang und so viel, das kann ich jetzt gar nicht alles aufzählen.
Was ja viele nicht, also was heißt viele nicht, was kein Mensch weiß,
ist, was eigentlich so zwischen diesen ganzen Installationen abgegangen ist.
Also dieses Blink Lights Ding, das hat uns ja so von null auf hundert so internationalen
Medienkünstlern hochkatapultiert und es gab dann wirklich so eine Phase von so ein,
zwei, drei Jahren, da war ich echt viel unterwegs auf diesem Planeten und hab
Vorträge gehalten über Blink Lights, Aber ich hab das dann auch immer genutzt
so ein bisschen CCC und Hackerkultur in den Fokus zu rücken.
Und da war ich halt von Japan bis Brasilien, also wirklich quer über den Planeten
verteilt, hier und da immer mal wieder im Einsatz.
Und was halt auch kam, waren halt Anfragen aus aller Welt.
Also gut Toronto hat geklappt, Paris hat geklappt, aber zwischendurch gab's halt von überall,
also wirklich von überall, haben mir Leute irgendwie,
ja hier guck mal das Haus, wär das nicht schick, pipapo und so und natürlich,
klar denkt man sich so, ja wär vielleicht schick, aber es hatte dann,
sagen wir mal, die sonstigen Rahmenbedingungen haben nicht gestimmt,
aber es gab halt auch so ein paar Sachen,
Wo es dann eben auch wirklich mal schon konkreter wurde und teilweise auch Projekte,
die erst auf den letzten Metern gescheitert sind, während wir also schon Pläne schmiedeten,
aber wo dann, was weiß ich, das Funding ausgefallen ist oder die Zusagen zu
spät kamen und so weiter,
all das hab ich dann auch nicht jetzt in zu viel Details wiedergegeben,
aber mal so einen Überblick gegeben und auch so ein paar Ideen,
die wir noch hatten, die nie realisiert wurden, etc.
Ja könnt da reinhören. Achso ja und am Schluss hab ich natürlich noch über unser
kleines Blinklights Polychrom, was wir da auf dem Camp gemacht haben, noch berichtet.
Dann zusammen mit dem Björn auch so ein bisschen die Technik nochmal erläutert,
die dort zum Einsatz kam. Ja die dann schon doch komplett anders war als zuletzt in unseren Sachen.
Was halt jetzt mal richtig mit led und farbe und so weiter war
ja dazu mehr auch in der
nächsten frik show noch mal ja ja schön Ja
vortrag ist verlinkt und dann ist auch noch verlinkt in
den show notes der vortrag von kantorkel dominik und mir Den wir dann auf der
milly way stage gehalten haben
auch die war sehr schön Der vortrag hat den Disclosure Hack & Bug Muster,
aber dann haben wir uns dann gebeten, den auf Englisch zu halten,
deswegen haben wir den auf Englisch gehalten.
Also heißt der Disclosure Hack and Back, was natürlich nicht ganz so lustig
ist wie Hack und Back, weil Hack und Back natürlich eine Referenz ist an alte LMP-Folgen.
Wir haben ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, wie wir eine Ransomware-Gang infiltriert haben.
Wir waren auf deren Command-and-Control-Server durch einen Hinweis,
den wir bekommen hatten, und haben dann quasi die Opfer,
wo wir gesehen haben, dass die sich mit diesem Command-and-Control-Server verbunden
haben oder deren Daten dort lagen, die haben wir dann informiert.
Darüber, dass sie gerade kompromittiert wurden und ihnen da wird teilweise geholfen,
die Angreifer noch loszuwerden.
Teilweise waren wir auch zu spät, aber es war eine sehr unterhaltsame Zeit in
den letzten Monaten, diese Ransomware-Gang zu infiltrieren.
Wir haben extra nicht gesagt, welche das ist, weil wir hoffen,
dass dieser Vortrag, dass dass es etwas dauert, bis die sich irgendwann in diesem
Vortrag sehen. Ja, wir hatten einen.
Aber so, irgendwann werden sie halt erkennen, dass das ihr Root-Home-Folder
ist, was da auf unseren Folien ist.
Und dann, bis dahin machen wir nochmal ordentlich Backups. Aber ja,
war sehr schön und im Anschluss daran, da kommen wir gleich nochmal in den Themen
drauf, durfte ich natürlich die ein oder andere Hackback Diskussion führen.
Weil, was wir da gemacht haben, war natürlich ein Hackback, beziehungsweise
uns haben die ja gar nicht gehackt, insofern war es noch nicht mal ein Back.
War einfach ein ganz normaler Hack, aber genau da durfte ich mich dann an mehreren
Stellen, wurde ich dann gefragt, wie ich denn gegen Hackback wäre und das aber dann selber mache.
Und naja, kann ich eigentlich bei dieser Gelegenheit direkt nochmal sagen,
das habe ich auch schon immer gesagt, Bei den Hackback-Diskussionen geht es ja nicht darum,
dass es quasi in den wenigen seltenen klitzekleinen Randfällen wie jetzt vielleicht
auch diesem unter Umständen einen kleinen Vorteil bietet,
wenn man Angreifende infiltriert, sondern es geht in diesen Diskussionen um
weitreichende offensive Befugnisse für den Staat und seine Sicherheitsbehörden, die
sie damit herbei argumentieren, sie bräuchten das für Hackback,
die sie aber, du wirst quasi keine Definition dieser Befugnis finden,
die sich nicht relativ übel ausnutzen lässt für viele andere Dinge.
Also würde man den Fall, den wir da jetzt hatten, irgendwie formalisiert abbilden
wollen, dann wäre das etwas, was aus einer staatlichen Perspektive präventiv gewesen wäre.
Also wir haben ja die gehackt, um weitere Angriffe zu verhindern.
Und damit hättest du quasi, wenn man das jetzt in eine allgemeingültige Regel
schreiben würde und sagt,
das ist jetzt etwas, wozu der Staat befugt ist, dann hast du ein ganz,
ganz fürchterliches Missbrauchspotenzial und eine sehr weitreichende Befugnis
zum Eingriff in Grundrechte geschaffen.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass es hier, vielleicht würde ich argumentieren,
wir haben vielleicht nach dem kategorischen Imperativ gehandelt,
dass das, was wir getan haben, unsere Aktion selber in Ordnung war,
aber dass es nicht dazu genügt oder dass es keinen Grund gibt,
nun eine allgemeine Befugnis für Staaten zu schaffen.
Das ist mir relativ wichtig in diesem Kontext zu sagen. Und noch dazu,
wir haben am Ende relativ wenig Schaden wirklich verhindert.
Auch das finde ich wichtig dazu zu sagen. jetzt natürlich Leute daherkommen und sagen,
ja, hier Hackback, total gut und jetzt wollen wir nur eine Sache noch,
wir wollen nicht irgendwelche Aktivisten, die das aus Spaß machen,
sondern wir wollen staatlich mandatiertes Handeln und da bin ich nach wie vor nicht für.
Naja.
So dann warst du aber auch noch DJ.
Ja, im Anschluss an unsere Sendung war das ja.
Ich hab mit meinem, der Vortrag war ja mit Kollegen von mir und aufgelegt hab
ich dann auch noch mit einem Kollegen von mir, mit Baltasar.
Da wurde ich dann während wir aufgelegt haben auch darauf hingewiesen,
dass unser Soundcloud Account immer noch keine 3000 Follower hat und das bemängel ich.
Das kreide ich jetzt hier nochmal an. Erstens klickt ihr jetzt auf den Vortrag
von Cantorke, Dominik und mir und dann klickt ihr auf das DJ Set und dann klickt
ihr auf Like, Subscribe, Glocke. Kann ja nicht so schwer sein.
Ja mir ist das wichtig.
Ja ja, dein fragiles Ego Linus, das ist wirklich schlimm.
Aber du hast es ja auch nötig.
Genau und ich wollte, oder willst du noch ein bisschen meine DJ Künste loben?
Das war alles gut, was ich da gehört habe. Ich hab jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit
daneben gestanden, aber ich konnte mich nicht beklagen. Ich mag den Sound, den du da produzierst.
Wir haben noch, die Lea Oswald, die hat eine tolle Fotoserie auf Flickr mit
viel buntem Licht vom Camp.
Die hab ich auch noch mit in die Shownotes getan.
Lea ist vielleicht einigen bekannt, ist unter anderem Betreiberin von Chaos.social,
zusammen mit Rix und auch eine umtriebige, gute Fotografin.
Die hat da auch einige Objekte, wo ich auch Schwierigkeiten hatte,
die zu fotografieren, hat sie sehr gut abgelichtet.
Tolle Fotoserie, kann ich auch empfehlen. Könnt ihr auch Like,
Like, Subscribe, Glocke. Könnt ihr bei Lea auch machen.
Es sind auch sehr, wie soll ich sagen, datenschutzaware Fotos,
also wenn ihr das Gefühl habt, es war niemand da auf dem Camp.
Doch, da waren schon überall Leute.
Ja, da waren aber auch überall Schilder. Also ich sag mal, ich bin ja quasi
einer der Hauptautoren der Fotopolicy, so wie sie da steht, da habe ich die
glaube ich irgendwann mal formuliert.
Die gab es doch schon vorher, aber wir haben sie dann irgendwann nochmal umformuliert.
Elektra hatte mich irgendwann mal darauf angesprochen, hat gesagt,
Linus, wir müssen uns über diese Photopolicy auch mal Gedanken machen,
weil wir werden in 20 Jahren zurückblicken auf diese Riesen-Events und da ist
auf den Bildern einfach kein Mensch. Und das ist natürlich schon...
So sieht's aus.
Es führt halt zu, also ich bin nach wie vor, stehe ich hinter dieser Fotopolicy.
Ich finde es auch grundsätzlich einfach nicht in Ordnung, Menschen ohne ihre
Einwilligung zu fotografieren.
Aber man wird sich vielleicht auch mal überlegen können oder zumindest bei Leuten.
Ich glaube, die Fotopolicy sollte so bleiben.
Aber man kann auch mal überlegen, dass es eben vielleicht auch okay ist,
wenn irgendwo im Hintergrund jemand verschwommen ist oder so, ja?
Oder dass man das Bild vielleicht macht und die Person dann nochmal blört oder
so, aber ja, es waren Leute da.
Definitiv, kann ich auch bestätigen, sehr sehr viele sogar.
Gut, lass uns zu den Themen voranschreiten, die wir jetzt hier auf Alyssa haben.
Thema Hackback. Das FBI hat QuackBot lahmgelegt.
QuackBot ist ein relativ großes Botnet, so im Prinzip so ein Trojaner-Botnet.
QuackBot habe ich auch im Rahmen beruflicher Tätigkeit mal gesehen im Zusammenhang
mit Ransomware-Fällen.
Jedenfalls hat das FBI deren Command and Control Server übernommen und hat 700.000,
infizierte Rechner quasi übernommen und befreit.
Wieder so eine Sache, ist das jetzt ein Hackback oder nicht?
Dürfen jetzt, dürfen jetzt nicht, darf Deutschland das?
Ich würde wieder sagen, natürlich ist das gut.
Warum sollten sie das jetzt nicht dürfen? Also welchen Teil dürften sie da nicht dürfen wollen?
Also ich kenne die US-Situation nicht, aber in Deutschland wäre das grundsätzlich
das Eindringen in ein fremdes Computersystem, ja.
Und potenziell, das war ja die Diskussion auch...
Wann war denn Deutschland das erste Mal mit sowas zusammen? Da hatten sie auch eine Situation.
De facto, wenn die jetzt, also de facto, wenn die deinem Rechner sagen,
trenne dich von diesem Botnet?
Dann greift ja der Staat in die Integrität deines Computers ein.
Und natürlich hat er dafür erstmal nicht unbedingt die Befugnis.
Und meine Position dazu ist, die sollte er auch nicht haben.
Ich finde das total in Ordnung, dass er das nicht darf.
Und ich finde es auch in Ordnung, dass Kathorke, Dominik und ich nicht eine
Ransomware-Gang hacken dürfen.
Es aber trotzdem gemacht haben
und dass wir nun in Anführungszeichen das Damoklesschwert über uns haben,
dass irgendeiner der uns jetzt verklagen könnte, ich sag mal die Ransomware
Gang könnte sagen, uns sind hier Millionen entgangen, wir klagen auf Schadensersatz.
Oder eines der betroffenen Opfer könnte sagen, ey ihr habt unsere AD-Dumps ausgewertet,
obwohl ihr das nicht durftet, um uns dann zu warnen, dass wir gehackt wurden.
Ja, ist in Ordnung. Und jetzt finde ich, ich finde das auf eine Weise in Ordnung,
dass es so ist, weil wir dadurch nämlich nicht irgendwie auf sicherem auf sicherem
Boden der Befugnis irgendwas machen und dann zu weit gehen,
sondern sehr genau und umsichtig vorgegangen sind, weil wir etwas Illegales
getan haben und darauf achten mussten, dass wir keine Kläger-,
kein Richter-Situation haben.
Und wenn der Staat jetzt diese Befugnis hätte und sowas am laufenden Band machen
würde, dann würden die allen möglichen Scheiß machen können und könnten dann
sagen, ja, sind wir aber befugt zu.
Deswegen finde ich es gut, dass niemand diese Befugnis hat und finde es trotzdem auch gut,
wenn dann in seltenen Fällen so etwas passiert und wir so eine Grauzone haben,
wo man am Ende kein Kläger, kein Richter Situationen hat.
Also vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz klar machen was sozusagen auf den betroffenen 700.000,
Computern dann getan wurde, also wenn ich es richtig sehe hat das FBI ohne denen
jetzt Bescheid zu sagen einfach einen Uninstaller exekutiert,
der quasi die Malware von diesen Systemen runtergenommen hat.
Ich kann mir schwerlich ein Szenario vorstellen, bei dem irgendeiner dieser
Betreiber sich darüber groß beklagen wird und es hat so ein bisschen was,
jetzt sind wir eh schon in schlechten Vergleichen, aber es ist so ein bisschen
wie so dein Haus ist on fire und dann kommt halt die Feuerwehr und tritt die
Tür ein und löscht das Feuer und hat nicht vorher nochmal angerufen und gefragt
ob das jetzt in deinem Interesse ist.
Ja, kann ja sein, dass ich das, ich meine, die haben auch, muss man hier sagen,
die haben einen Administrator irgendwie von Quackbot infiziert.
Das heißt, da sind die jetzt, das ist dann, die haben also aktiv gehackt den
Rechner eines dieser Co-Conspirators dort und Es ist schwierig,
Gesetze so zu schreiben, dass man denen das und nur das erlaubt und nicht ein
fürchterliches Missbrauchspotential hat.
Und ja, das dürfte deutsche Behörden vermutlich nicht ohne weiteres eine Zielperson hacken.
Also müsste ich den Fall nochmal genau mir anschauen und dann nochmal die Gesetzeslage,
ob man das jetzt in Deutschland dürfte oder nicht.
Ist ja auch die Frage, ob jetzt quasi in dem Moment, wo das Botnetz als solches
zentral übernommen und ausgeschaltet wurde, ob dann sozusagen von diesen Dateien
auf den Rechnern überhaupt noch eine Gefahr ausging.
Das kann ich natürlich jetzt nicht beurteilen, das hängt jetzt sehr von dem Büro ab.
Wird ja dann im Rahmen der der sogenannten aktiven Cyber Abwehr auch diskutiert,
dass man dann zum Beispiel sagt, wir könnten das Netz trennen oder so.
Ja, aber nochmal, das Entscheidende ist,
das sind hier technische, höchst detaillierte Einzelfälle, jeweils immer besondere
Konstellationen und so weiter, ja.
Und dem gegenüber hast du eine Horde Scharfmacher, die sagen,
irgendwas muss der Staat ja jetzt machen.
Und am Ende irgendwo hinschreiben wollen, der Staat darf jetzt hacken.
Und das geht halt schief.
Es geht darum, ich finde das in Ordnung, dass das in einer rechtlichen Grauzone
ist im Zweifelsfall besser aufgehoben,
als mit einer weitreichenden Befugnis, wie man jetzt versucht,
beispielsweise das BKA dann zu bekommen.
Also ich meine in dem Moment wo dieser Uninstall unter Umständen Kollateralschäden verursacht hätte,
weil auch dieser Uninstaller kann ja einen Fehler enthalten,
ich weiß es ist jetzt unklar ob dieser Uninstaller der von der Malware Gang
selber war oder ob das etwas ist.
Ich hab keines im Aninstaller für ihre Malware, das gehört nicht unbedingt zu
deren Produktumfang. Sicher?
Also nicht das hier, ja gut ich dachte vielleicht so als Notfall,
was weiß ich, keine Ahnung ob die etwas gefunden haben, also der war vielleicht
nicht auf den Systemen aber vielleicht hat er doch existiert.
Wie auch immer, also auf jeden Fall kann man ja, also gerade in dem Moment wo
das FBI selber einen geschrieben hat, kann es natürlich immer sein,
dass durch einen Fehler oder durch Missverständnis dann sozusagen andere Daten
auch noch mit Leidenschaft gezogen werden und dann ist das Geschrei natürlich groß.
Egal, kann man jetzt tausendfach noch ausiterieren.
Hat auf jeden Fall stattgefunden, Quackbot habe ich natürlich vorher noch nie
gehört, das sind alles so Dinge von denen man eigentlich erst erfährt wenn sie weg sind.
Ja ich hab wie gesagt schon vorher davon gehört die machen das war eine der
einer der großen Initial Schadsoftware wo du dann nachher irgendwie Ransomware
bekommen hast von Conti,
Prolog, R-Evil, Rans, Mega, Cortex, Black Buster solche das war schon die waren
ganz gut im Geschäft, das FBI hat auch offenbar eine Datei mit dem Namen.
Payments.txt und da wird gesagt,
dass nur die Quackbordleute, die ja dann auch nicht die komplette Ransom kriegen,
sondern einen Anteil, dass sie in den letzten 18 Monaten 58 Millionen es doller gemacht hätten.
Jo, dann gibt's auch noch so was.
Es haben Hacker eine Stalkerware gehackt, die den Namen Web Detective hat,
auf portugiesischer Sprache beworben wird, primär in Brasilien genutzt wird.
Und die haben die Kundschaft, die Daten über die Kundschaft,
also über die Bezahlenden für diese Stalkerware, 1,5 Gig haben sie an DDO Secrets gegeben.
Und die vielen Terabyte Daten von den Opfern, also betroffenen Personen,
die diese Stalkerware auf ihren Systemen hatten, die haben sie gelöscht.
Was ist DDO Secrets?
Die hier aus Secrets ist so eine Leaking-Seite. Die haben wir auch,
glaube ich, öfter mal verlinkt.
Die in letzter Zeit gerne mal Distributed Denial of Secrets,
weiß nicht genau, Name, wie auch immer, ja.
Aber die haben, da findest du relativ viele Leaks. Und die haben unter anderem.
So unterschiedliche Levels an Whistleblower-Leaks und unter anderem teilweise
haben sie dann Limited Distribution,
weil da bei diesem Web Detective ist das jetzt so, dass sie es nur an Journalistinnen
und Forscherinnen rausgeben, da musst du dann eben sagen, ich bin so und so
und ich möchte das mir anschauen.
Das heißt, das ist nicht frei zugänglich.
Die geben das nur bestimmten Personen. Let me spy haben sie auch,
ist auch so ein Stalkerware-Ding, glaube ich.
Und teilweise haben sie aber auch Dinge, die sind dann nicht in Limited Distribution,
sondern geben es einfach allen. Genau. Ja, finde ich auch ganz gut.
Waren auch mal wieder erstaunlich viele Daten.
Ja, so wird viel genutzt offenbar diese Stalkerware und das ist ja eine ganz
ekelhafte Geschichte, ne?
Also im Prinzip Trojaner Software, die üblicherweise von Männern auf die Smartphones
von Frauen gespielt wird.
Kann es sicherlich auch umgekehrt geben, aber das wird, so die Werbung richtet
sich schon sehr stark an Männer.
Das ist wirklich, würde ich sagen, richtig niedrig, richtig ekelhaft sowas erstens
zu nutzen und dann auch noch sowas zu verkaufen, anzubieten.
Ich glaubt. Weltschlecht.
Ja. Dann war ich, ich weiß nicht ob ich, die letzte Sendung ist so lange her,
ich glaube ich habe es nicht erzählt, dass ich in so einer ZDF Doku war,
über, habe ich das erzählt?
Digital Fail Deutschland im Datenstau?
Weiß es nicht, glaube nicht.
Ja, eine ganz ganz lustige ZDF Doku über,
oder hab ich das jetzt, ist doch egal, ich erzähl es nochmal,
Doku darüber wie Deutschland es verkackt, ja?
Und da durfte ich viele Fails kommentieren, darstellen.
Dann haben sie irgendwie auch sehr schöne Beispiele rausgesucht,
wo dann irgendwie so irgendwelche,
wie heißt das, wenn man studiert, BAföG-Antrag, kannst du digital stellen,
und am anderen Ende wird dann das, was du digital eingegeben hast,
ausgedruckt, und dann kriegst du einen Brief zurück.
Also wo sie mal wieder so richtig den Prozess so richtig schön digitalisiert haben.
Und das war sehr, das ist eine Doku, die dann mal zeigt, wie katastrophal schlecht
das in Deutschland läuft.
Ja, das ist so. Da haben wir jetzt auch noch ein paar andere Meldungen zu dem Thema.
Die Ampel-Koalition hat Halbzeit und ja, ich weiß auch nicht,
das ist ja auch ein Trauerspiel.
Da läuft vieles nicht so gut.
Christian Lindner macht das, was man von ihm erwarten konnte.
Also mit dem Typen zu koalieren oder überhaupt mit der FDP zu koalieren,
muss man sich glaube ich sehr, sehr gut überlegen.
Oh, das muss echt der Schmerz im Arsch sein schlichtweg,
das ist wirklich, jetzt waren sie ja gerade auf Schloss Meseberg und haben sich
vertragen und, oh, das ist schon, das tut wirklich weh, ne.
Und ich find's dramatisch, weil das natürlich auch medial die ganze Zeit so
begleitet wird. Und ehrlich gesagt, sag ich mal...
Jetzt so vorher die Koalitionen, irgendwelche CDU-geführten Koalitionen,
die haben keine bessere Politik gehabt.
Aber irgendwie hat die SPD da halt auch nicht gestritten, sondern einfach so,
ja, nö, müssen wir ja machen, ist ja jetzt alternativlos oder so.
Und ich glaube so ein bisschen, das Problem ist, dass jetzt,
sag ich mal, bei den Leuten, die so große Koalitionen wählen,
denen ist das halt, oder die, die CDU wählen, denen ist das völlig egal.
Wie scheiße die Bande ist, oder wie inkompetent die sich anstellen,
während bei intelligenten Menschen wählen ja nicht CDU.
Und dann hast du halt eine Situation,
dass jetzt die Leute sich das anschauen und nur mit dem Kopf schütteln und die
Ampel hat jetzt Zustimmungsraten von 19 Prozent, Das ist irgendwie schlechter als Joe Biden, ja?
Und jetzt wird halt mal nach der Hälfte der Zeit gesagt, okay,
was habt ihr denn umgesetzt?
Der Bitkom sagt, ja, im Koalitionsvertrag standen 334 Digitalisierungsvorhaben,
davon habt ihr bisher 11% erledigt.
Mindestbandbreite in Deutschland soll Mitte 2023 angehoben werden auf mindestens
15 Mbit Downstream und etwas mehr als die aktuellen 1,7 Mbit Upstream.
Spannendes Versprechen. Das wird aber verschoben.
Und was die Freiheitsrechte angeht, wo man sich jetzt durchaus was hätte erhoffen
können von Grünen und FDP, die ja eigentlich in dieser Richtung immer sehr,
sehr gut sich positioniert haben.
So ein Satz von Staatstrojanern soll runtergefahren werden. Das ist eher so
ein halbherziges Gesetzesvorhaben.
In Sachen Chat-Kontrolle haben wir eine sehr wankelmütige Haltung.
Eine leider nicht besonders kompetente Innenministerin, in diesem Fachbereich
zumindest nicht besonders kompetente Innenministerin.
Und da hätte man sich auch natürlich was sehr viel Besseres gewünscht.
Dann soll jetzt das BND-Gesetz reformiert werden, werden wir in der nächsten Sendung behandeln.
Da gab es dann eine für 88 Seiten Gesetzesentwurf, mal wieder so eine Stellungnahme,
eine Frist für die Stellungnahme von 24 Stunden und 30 Minuten.
Dafür hätten wir nicht, da hätten wir auch Christdemokraten wählen können.
Wieso, kannst du das auch heute einfach in deine AI reinschmeißen?
Schreibe eine Stellungnahme in die CCC.
Das ist egal, der liest sich die 88 Seiten noch in nullkommanix durch.
Am Ende ist es auch nicht euch egal, da hört ja sowieso keiner zu,
wenn du das dann Stellungnahme veröffentlicht.
Public Money, Public Code wäre schön, sehen wir auch wenig von. Ja, also das ist.
Also ich muss sagen, ich würde jetzt auch nicht davon ausgehen,
dass zu 50 Prozent einer Legislaturperiode 50 Prozent aller Vorhaben umgesetzt sind. Ja das stimmt.
Begonnen und angeschoben werden und so weiter, jetzt kann man natürlich trefflich
darüber streiten was die richtige Zahl wäre und ob sich das zu diesem Zeitpunkt machen kann.
Kann ja durchaus sein, dass der Rest sich jetzt im nächsten Quartal quasi,
also nicht im Jahresquartal, sondern im Legislaturquartal, also im nächsten
Jahr, dann auf einmal massenhaft materialisiert.
Allein mir fehlt ein wenig der Glaube, weil ich einfach auch immer noch nicht
so die richtige, das Gefühl habe, dass wir schon mit der richtigen Generation arbeiten.
Was meinst du jetzt mit Generation?
Altersgeneration. Also da steckt schon noch zu viel.
Muss deine Generation ran oder? Meine.
Ich setze eher auf Deine ehrlich gesagt, weil so in meiner Generation war das
ja auch alles noch nicht so verbreitet.
Also ich bin da ja, ich bin ja eigentlich gar nicht offiziell Teil meiner eigenen
Generation. Ich bin ja Generationsflüchtling.
Suche in jüngeren Generationen Schutz. Die ein wenig mehr, wie soll ich sagen,
mehr so meinen Vorstellungen entspricht.
Es kam ja schon immer alle hier mit diesem, wie hieß es, native,
digital native, das wurde ja dann immer nur Jüngeren zugeschrieben.
Moment, Moment, Moment, ich bin doch auch… Wer hat denn alles umgebaut?
Ich war schon dabei, nehmt mich mit.
Du warst quasi vor den Native Star.
Ich war schon Native Star, da waren die anderen noch gar nicht geboren.
Ja, ein ähnliches Ding spielt sich ja jetzt auch gerade in der ganzen Diskussion
um die Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens ab.
Wir hatten das Thema hier schon mehrfach und schmerzhaft berichtet.
Jetzt ist ja Herr Lauterbach unterwegs und versucht sich da durch das Dickicht
zu schlagen und jetzt gibt es neue Gesetzespläne,
um denn nun diese ganze Digitalisierung im Gesundheitswesen voranzubringen und ihr ahnt es schon,
es geht hier primär um das elektronische Rezept auf einer Seite und die digitale
Gesundheitsakte auf der anderen Seite.
Nebst anderen Maßnahmen sicherlich, die das flankieren, aber das sind so die
primären Produkte und da ist ja auch was dran.
Also die Verheißung davon ist ja, dass man eben wegkommt vom Rezeptzettel und
mit einem elektronischen Rezept den ganzen Flow optimiert.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, das war jetzt das, was mich primär...
Gehemmt hat, also ich bin auch mit dem Rezept auf Papier bisher gut klar gekommen.
Das ging schon immer gut. Man kommt vom Arzt, hat den Zettel in der Hand,
dann geht man unten in die Apotheke rein und dann hat man eigentlich in der
Regel, wenn es denn schon vorrätig ist und spätestens nach 24 Stunden hat man dann auch sein Rezept.
Also das ist sozusagen gar nicht so sehr wichtig.
Du meinst dein Rezept hast du sofort, du meinst dein Medizin.
Also was mir verschrieben wurde sozusagen. Also das war eigentlich in Deutschland
aus meiner Perspektive zumindest nie ein Thema.
Nichtsdestotrotz gibt's natürlich auch durchaus Punkte für so ein E-Rezept,
weil dann wird das halt irgendwo gespeichert und dann kann man darüber eine
Statistik machen und was ist denn eigentlich verschrieben worden etc.
Und idealerweise geht es ja dann auch in meine Verschreibungshistorie mit ein,
an der ich ja selber ein Interesse haben kann, sprich digitale Patientenakte oder Gesundheitsakte.
Aber geht's bei diesem E-Rezept nicht primär darum, dass man irgendwie Doc Morris und so einfacher macht?
Das ist natürlich dann der nächste Schritt. Also ich weiß nicht,
ob das das primäre Ziel ist, aber es ermöglicht natürlich auch solche Dinge,
damit auch das Viagra online verschrieben werden kann.
Ich krieg da gerne mal auch gute Angebote per E-Mail.
Für Viagra? Tatsächlich?
Die landen bei mir immer im Spam.
Wirklich? Dann warte mal noch 10 Jahre. Dann hast du einen anderen Filter.
Ja, aber die wärmen wir der Regel auch damit, dass das Rezept frei ist.
Es macht natürlich in dem Moment keinen Sinn, wo sagen wir mal klar ist,
also du hast jetzt ein verschreibungspflichtiges Medikament eines Patienten,
der das regelmäßig bekommt aber auch immer wieder ein Rezept braucht,
um es sich holen zu können.
Es macht natürlich keinen Sinn, dass du dafür dann einen Termin machst,
dich in eine halbe Stunde in die Straßenbahn setzt, zum Arzt fährst,
nur um dort irgendwie am Counter so ein ausgedrucktes Rezept abzuholen.
Also von daher, da ist natürlich was dran und warum sollte das auch nicht so laufen.
Um das also jetzt alles zu beschleunigen gibt es jetzt eine neue Reihe von Gesetzen,
die all das beschleunigen sollen und da geht es natürlich primär um die Umsetzung.
Eigentlich sollen ja die ganzen Arztpraxen schon in der Lage sein,
diese Gesundheitsakten zu befüllen und ihr Rezept auszustellen.
Das haben wir hier schon ein paar Mal thematisiert.
Aus verschiedensten Gründen ist es halt nicht so weit. Da wird also nochmal
nachgelegt und das Ganze soll also dann zum 1.
Januar 24 eine Pflicht werden für Ärzte, dass sie E-Rezepte ausstellen können müssen.
Obwohl es eben eigentlich schon seit zwei Jahren dann soweit gewesen sein soll.
Diese E-Rezepte werden zentral gespeichert und naja, dann geht's halt los.
Dann muss man wieder Apps benutzen, braucht Smartphones, um das alles irgendwie durchzuführen.
Unter anderem ist auch geplant, dass dieser Abruf dieser Rezepte dann in Krankenkassen-Apps
möglich ist. und man hält sich hier auf.
Ausweisapp 2 braucht oder sowas. Um das durchzumachen.
Was so ein bisschen umstritten ist jetzt in dieser ganzen Maßnahme ist,
dass um quasi die Gesundheitsakten auch wirklich zum Erfolg zu führen,
also dass es auch wirklich benutzt wird, soll es von Opt-in auf Opt-out umgestellt werden.
Sprich man kriegt halt einfach eine eingerichtet, es sei denn man spricht sich explizit dagegen aus.
Keine Ahnung, inwiefern sowas mit der DSGVO vereinbar sein wird oder ist,
aber das ist wohl Teil dieser Pläne.
Bisher gibt es wohl nur so bei ein Prozent der Patienten eine E-Aktie,
was ich schon für eine relativ hohe Zahl halte im Übrigen.
Das Bundesgesundheitsministerium möchte aber gerne auf 80 Prozent kommen im Jahre 2025.
Und das ist dann sozusagen der Weg, der hier beschritten werden soll.
Naja, ein Abfallprodukt davon, insbesondere auch der zentralen Verschreibung
und der Patientenakte, ist natürlich die sicherlich auch umstrittene medizinische
Forschung, die Zugriff bekommen soll. Auch auf, quasi auf Opt-Out-Basis.
Das heißt, man wird dann auch irgendwann sagen können, so ja,
hier darf für Forschung benutzt werden, also natürlich dann pseudonymisiert.
Ich verstehe die Motivation, ganz ehrlich. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
wie das rechtlich zu beurteilen ist, aber wenn man halt die medizinische Forschung
in Deutschland beschleunigen möchte in diesem Bereich, ist es natürlich klar,
dass diese Daten sehr wertvoll sein können.
Weil man damit natürlich sehr viel mehr Leute auswerten kann,
also nicht die Leute auswerten kann, sondern den medizinischen Verlauf auswerten
kann, um neue Erkenntnisse über die Wirksamkeit vor den bestimmten Maßnahmen
oder bestimmten Medikamenten zu bekommen.
Tja, ja der Lauterbach hat ja dann auch auf die Frage, also das mit dem Opt-out,
ich bin mir da irgendwie, ich bin kein Jurist, aber ich glaube sowas einzuführen
mit nur Opt-out, muss man sich auf jeden Fall anstrengen.
Lauterbach sagt ja dann haben sie eine schlechtere medizinische Versorgung.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, ja.
Immerhin hat das so gegeben, dass Deutschland Entwicklungsland ist in diesem Bereich.
Ja gut, das, äh, Breaking News, man könnte auch von der digitalen dritten Welt
sprechen, die wir hier langsam darstellen.
Ja, ich denke halt, also meine Sorge ist, wenn ich mir anschaue,
wie wir in anderen Digitalfeldern eine Katastrophe nach der anderen bauen,
sehe ich einfach keine Hoffnung, dass wir das im Bereich der Medizindaten nicht machen.
Und entsprechend sehe ich das sehr kritisch, wenn das jetzt auf einmal schnell
und ambitioniert laufen soll.
Gleichzeitig sage ich ja auch, wenn du irgendwie Sachen hinkriegen willst,
dann musst du die halt einfach mal ambitioniert und ordentlich machen.
Ich glaube Medizindaten ist enorm kompliziert als Datenstruktur abzubilden und
weil es kompliziert als Datenstruktur abzubilden ist,
wird es wahrscheinlich einfach nur so ein Graffel.
Da hast du wenigstens alle Daten da, aber das ist trotzdem nicht sinnvoll sortiert
oder einsehbar. Das ist so ein bisschen meine Erwartung in dieser Angelegenheit.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es richtig, wenn du das mit Opt-out machst,
wirst du keine sehr hohen Adoptionsraten bekommen.
Das stimmt schon.
Es ist ein schwieriges Feld.
Du meinst, wenn man das mit Opt-in macht, dann hat man keinen hohen Adressumsatz?
Ja sorry natürlich, genau. Wenn du sagst, du musst dich aktiv dafür anmelden,
dann werden Leute das einfach nicht machen und dann brauchst du das gar nicht zu machen.
Gleichzeitig, unter der Annahme, dass sie es ordentlich machen würden,
fände ich es auch in Ordnung, das mit Opt-out zu machen, aber da sie es nicht
ordentlich machen, wäre ich eigentlich lieber für ein Opt-in.
Also ich bin vor allem von der technischen Implementierung bisher noch nicht sonderlich überzeugt.
Das ist einfach, sieht alles noch nicht besonders perfekt aus,
das ist halt wie wir schon mehrfach berichtet haben, mehr so eine Art Medizindropbox,
wo irgendwelche komischen Dokumente reingeschmissen werden, anstatt dass es
einfach eine wohl sortierte, klar strukturierte Datenbank ist.
Nur das hätte am Ende wirklich einen Sinn.
Mein Gott, fang mal mit irgendwas an und dann mach das irgendwann nochmal neu.
Und dann wird's geleakt und dann. Ja.
Also meine Prognose ist mit diesen ganzen Erwartungshaltungen,
80 Prozent und so weiter werden das nutzen,
das ist einfach, das ist ein Fiebertraum, ja auf keinen Fall,
also vielleicht kommt man auf 80 Prozent, die keinen Out gewählt haben,
ja das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Aber dass das irgendwie aktiv vollständig genutzt wird und befüllt wird und
auch korrekt durchgeführt wird, das glaube ich da können wir uns dann doch von
trennen von diesem Gedanken, von daher wird's noch eine Weile dauern.
Und vielleicht landen wir in einer Situation,
in der dann eben die chronischen oder schwerkranken Menschen,
die auch große, wichtige Patientenakten mit tendenzwerten Informationen haben, das dann machen.
Und so gesunde Menschen, die ab und zu mal Blut abnehmen oder so,
jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein Ding pflegen.
Und dann hast du nicht 80 Prozent, dann hast du vielleicht 10 Prozent,
aber das sind dann vielleicht auch die 10 Prozent, auf die es ankommt oder so.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Gut.
Bleiben wir bei den Gesetzesvorhaben der Ampel-Koalition. Das Selbstbestimmungsgesetz.
Eigentlich nicht unbedingt so ein netzpolitisches Thema, aber beim Selbstbestimmungsgesetz
geht es um die Rechte von von transgeschlechtlichen,
intergeschlechtlichen, nichtbinären Menschen, die potenziell ihren Geschlechtseintrag
und damit verbunden öfter auch ihren Namen ändern möchten.
Und wenn du das bisher machen wolltest, musstest du zwei psychologische Gutachten
vorlegen, damit vor Gericht diese Änderung anerkannt wurde.
Und das ist natürlich relativ entwürdigend und unnötig und das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hatte das auch schon mehrmals für verfassungswidrig erklärt, dieses Vorgehen.
Da brauchen wir gar keine Diskussion darüber zu führen. Mit dem Selbstbestimmungsgesetz
soll es jetzt ausreichen, dass du beim Standesamt das erklärst.
Gehst zum Standesamt, sagst du so, hiermit stelle ich fest, Name so und so,
Geschlechtseintrag so und so fertig.
Und das wäre ja eigentlich auch alles gut. Jetzt kommen aber die Polizei Frei-
und Sicherheitsbehörden und sagen, sie möchten...
Sicherstellen, dass über diese Änderungen der gesamte Sicherheitsapparat der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
BKA, Inlandsgeheimdienst, Zoll, aktiv benachrichtigt werden,
wenn eine Person in Deutschland ihren Namen oder Geschlechtseintrag ändert.
Warum? Dann denkst du dir, wieso macht er das bis jetzt ja auch nicht?
Dann sagen sie, ja, sie gehen davon aus, dass das sehr oft dann verwendet wird.
Und es gibt außerdem das Offenbarungsverbot im Rahmen dieses Gesetzes,
dass nämlich der alte Name und der alte Geschlechtsantrag nach einer Änderung
nur noch in Ausnahmefällen offengelegt werden dürfen.
Ja, das macht auch Sinn, das so zu machen, weil die Menschen haben jetzt nur
mal gesagt, mein Name ist der und der und mein Geschlecht ist das und das.
Und die haben ja lange genug unter ihrer alten Zuweisung und zugeschriebenen Identität gelitten.
Gelitten die wollen die ja loswerden und dann brauchst du nicht irgendwelche
afd honks die jeden tag noch mal daran erinnern
Dass du mal ein anderes leben geführt hast Gegen deinen gegen dein gefühl und
gegen deinen willen ja Und insofern macht das auch sinn zu sagen nee dieser
name der wird jetzt nicht mehr genannt und dieses andere Geschlecht,
was da mal stand, das wird jetzt nicht wieder rausgekratzt oder steht auch nicht
hinter bis 2023 männlich, seitdem nicht binär oder was auch immer,
sondern das ist einfach grundsätzlich jetzt so.
Und da sagen aber die Sicherheitsbehörden und natürlich auch die Polizeigewerkschafter,
dass sie Angst haben, dass das jetzt von der organisierten Kriminalität...
Und von den Extremisten genutzt wird, um der Strafverfolgung zu entgehen.
Wir kennen ja die ganzen Terroristen, die sich dann noch das Geschlecht ändern
lassen, um besser ins Flugzeug zu kommen.
Ja, totaler Unsinn, aber ich glaube, auch das dürfen die gar nicht.
Ohne jetzt großartig deren religiöse Gesetze da gelesen zu haben,
würde ich sagen, Wahrscheinlich dürfen die nicht ihr Geschlecht ändern,
aber auf jeden Fall hängt da jetzt so eine,
da hast du schon so eine schöne Entwicklung, dass du ein Freiheitsrecht,
ein Grundrecht mal vernünftig ermöglichst, eine verfassungswidrige Praxis loswerden
willst, du musst aber vom Psychologen dir das attestieren lassen und so weiter.
Und jetzt kommen sie dran und wollen den ganzen Mist dann irgendwie noch zu
so einem Sicherheitsthema machen.
Und das glaube ich auch, dass da wieder einfach nur irgendwelche Spinner sich
irgendwas herbeifantasieren,
weil ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt irgendwie von
Kriminellen ausgenutzt wird.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt wirklich untertauchen möchtest und du
musst nur eine Erklärung beim Standesamt abgeben.
Ja, ja.
Das ist dann schon ein relativ einfacher Schritt in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also sagen wir mal so es wäre, wenn ich untertauchen will, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht damit anfangen beim Standesamt.
Also du bist ja nicht ausgerechnet.
Guten Tag.
Ich muss untertauchen.
Ich heiße jetzt Tanja.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so ein Alid.
Ja okay, Terrorismus sozusagen, Verfolgung gilt nicht als Grund.
Okay, also da bin ich mal gespannt. Also ich halte die,
diese ganze Sache für leicht übertrieben und ich glaube es wäre hier sinnvoller,
mal sich das Leben der Betroffenen anzuschauen.
Und wenn du mit Menschen sprichst, die das offiziell hinter sich gebracht haben,
mit diesen Gutachten und so weiter, die empfinden das als hart,
belastend und entwürdigend.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass die das irgendwie geil finden, dass man ihnen sagt,
ja, du kannst diesen Schritt machen, gar kein Problem.
Nur, wir machen dann eine Meldung an das BKA, die Bundespolizei,
das Bundesverwaltungsamt zum nationalen Waffenregister und zum Ausländerzentralregister,
dem Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge, dem Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz,
dem Bundesamt für den militärischen Abschirmdienst, dem jeweils zuständigen
Landeskriminalamt, dem Zollkriminalamt, den Hauptzollämtern der Finanzkontrolle
Schwarzarbeit und der Zentralstelle für Finanztransaktionsuntersuchung.
Bitte hier einmal unterschreiben.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, ob das...
Aber wäre das so schlimm? Also ich meine, das ändert ja jetzt sozusagen an dem Vorgang nichts.
Ich würde das zu beurteilen lieber den Menschen zulassen oder überlassen,
die vor dieser Entscheidung stehen.
Ist ein bisschen, ja wahrscheinlich werden die auch die Pille schlucken.
Die haben vorher irgendwie zwei psychologische Untersuchungen irgendwie gemacht,
um das zu dürfen. dürfen.
Die werden auch diese Pille schlucken. Die Frage ist, ob das jetzt irgendwie notwendig ist.
Weil wie gesagt, ich glaube, da ist nur wieder irgend so eine verkappte Transfeindlichkeit
hinter, dann irgendwie zu sagen, da könnte ja jetzt jeder kommen.
Ja genau darum geht es bei diesem Gesetz. Und, ähm, naja.
Lassen wir das an der Stelle mal offen. Aber ich hab den Eindruck Elon Musk
ist auch zum Standesamt gelatscht und hat gesagt ich muss auch unbedingt eine
Namensänderung vornehmen.
Reider heißt nämlich ja Twix und deswegen heißt Twitter jetzt X.
Haben wir hier noch gar nicht so besprochen, ist vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig.
Ich bin ja ehrlich gesagt sehr froh darüber, dass das jetzt umbenannt worden ist,
weil dadurch wird es mir leichter gemacht, Twitter in einer romantischen,
positiven Erinnerung vorzuhalten in meinem Kopf.
Aber ich bin ja schon ein bisschen angepisst, weil sozusagen jetzt so mein bevorzugter sozialer Netzraum,
ich weiß Twitter ganz furchtbar und alles und so weiter, aber jetzt ist es halt
richtig schlimm und es hatte ja auch seine guten Seiten,
jetzt kann ich aber sozusagen an Twitter romantisch zurückdenken und mir denken
so erst seitdem es X wurde war es richtig scheiße.
Stimmt nicht, aber man hat ja so seine kleinen Fluchten, denn X.
Was ist denn überhaupt mit dem los? Dieses X Ding, das probiert der ja schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Der wollte ja schon mal Paypal, glaub ich auch irgendwie irgendwas mit X umbenennen.
Und irgendwie hat der so ein Ding, so ein Rad am Wandern mit so einem Buchstaben X.
Damals wurde das wohl noch verhindert und sie haben ihm dann irgendwie gesagt
so geh mal aus der Sonne, mach mal was anderes irgendwie. Das heißt jetzt Paypal.
Und dann hat er SpaceX gegründet, ja, und jetzt ist ihm für Twitter wahrscheinlich
kein richtiger Präfix eingefallen.
So, TwitX oder PostX, Posted, äh, und jetzt einfach nur X.
Und ist ja dann auch allen völlig auf den Nuss gegangen, hat dann irgendwie
dieses riesige leuchtende blinkende krass weiß strahlende X oben auf dieses
Twitter-Headquarter draufgeballert,
was alle genervt hat, was natürlich auch gleich wieder demontiert werden musste,
weil er gar keine Genehmigung dafür hatte und so weiter und so weiter.
Ist ja auch völlig egal, auf jeden Fall dieser Schatten eines Netzwerks erlaubt
jetzt auch wieder den ganzen alten Scheiß, unter anderem Trump.
Ja Trump haben sie ja eh schon lange wieder erlaubt, der ist ja nur dann wiedergekommen.
Aber jetzt postet er was.
Genau jetzt hat er und was hat er gepostet seinen markt schottner
Damit hat
er sich zurück gemeldet ich hatte also dass er da wieder drauf darf
hat das war glaube ich eine der ersten amtshandlungen Und jetzt war er in einem
der vielen Verfahren ich weiß noch nicht mal genau welches aber wahrscheinlich
wegen 6 januar musste er dann zur polizei nicht zur polizei sondern zum Zu Justiz,
zum Gericht, glaube ich, hat er da seinen Markshot bekommen und natürlich hat
er den dann jetzt gerade getwittert.
Das war in Georgia im Übrigen, wo er ja jetzt seine vierte Anklage verpasst
bekommen hat, die insofern ja was besonderes ist, als dass sie ja nicht Bundesrecht unterliegt.
Also die bisherige Verfolgung rund um die ganzen Vorfälle zum 6.
Januar, also sozusagen der Sturm des Kapitols, den er da initiiert hat,
das wird jetzt über verschiedene gerichtliche Ebenen verfolgt.
Und unter anderem gibt es halt jetzt auch ein Related Case in Georgia,
da geht es halt konkret um die Wahlbeeinflussung in Georgia und das ist insofern was besonderes,
als dass einerseits das bedeutet, dass dort Landesrecht gilt und selbst wenn
er dann nochmal Präsident werden würde, er sich dann nicht selbst begnadigen lassen kann.
Hat sozusagen weiterreichende Funktionen, deswegen ist das besonders problematisch
und er hat es dort auch nochmal mit einer besonders scharfzüngigen Richterin zu tun,
die also hier alle Register zieht.
Unter anderem ihn auch genötigt hat diesen Mugshot anzufertigen.
Was ja immer, wenn jemand angeklagt und quasi erstmal formal festgenommen wird
in den USA, wird dieses Foto gemacht. Das ist ihm allerdings da auf Bundesebene
erlassen worden, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Hier nicht. Hat er natürlich genutzt, um dann gleich ganz Batman-Villain-mäßig
da in die Kamera zu gucken und gleich auf T-Shirts gedruckt und Pipapo.
Ist natürlich auch eine interessante Methode damit umzugehen.
Ja, und dann war das eben seine erste Amtshandlung auf X.
Währenddessen, genau, Trump zurück. Musk erlaubt jetzt wieder politische Werbung auf Twitter.
Und dann gab es noch so einen wunderschönen Fall, wo jemand Missbrauchsdarstellungen
verbreitet hat und sie haben den Account am Ende nicht dafür gelöscht.
Ja, weil und Begründung war irgendwie so,
ja, Ja, wir haben den Account ja kurzzeitig gesperrt,
DuDuDu gesagt, unsere höchste Priorität ist das Material zu entfernen und diesen Account,
den sie da gesperrt hatten, also es war ein Account mit 600.000,
Followern, der wurde am Mittwoch gesperrt, nachdem er zwei Screenshots aus einem
Video gepostet hatte, Video gepostet
hatte, in dem eine Misshandlung eines kleinen Kindes zu sehen war.
Da hat er gesagt, wir haben ja nur Leute aus unserem Team gesehen und deswegen
löschen wir jetzt die Posts und stellen den Account wieder her.
Der Typ, der das getwittert hat, sagt, es wäre ihm darum gegangen,
Kindern zu helfen. aber irgendwie komisch.
Das macht halt alles keinen Sinn, außer dass er eben wirklich dieses Netzwerk jetzt als,
keine Ahnung, also sozusagen die Basis seines Erfolgs ist quasi allen Radikalen
dort ihr Spieltrieb zu lassen und damit diese Plattform in irgendeiner Form zu popularisieren.
Und mir ist ehrlich gesagt schleierhaft, wie das langfristig erfolgreich sein
soll, weil der Ruf ist irgendwann halt auch komplett ruiniert oder ist er in
gewissen Kreisen natürlich jetzt auch schon.
Das Ding, das große Ziel ist ja quasi so aus diesem System so eine Art Universal
App zu machen, so dass sie irgendwie damit bezahlen können etc.
Also er öffnet im Prinzip so die Funktionalität von den großen chinesischen Chat-Apps nach.
Also das wird sich weit entfernen von dem was Zyber war.
Aber ich hätte auch, also Payment App kann ja verstehen,
aber ich hätte irgendwie, weiß ich nicht ob ich mich so wohlfühlen würde in
irgendeiner Social Network App,
wo ich noch dazu irgendwie mit politischer Werbung und rechtsextremer Scheiße
zugeballert werde, jetzt auch noch zu sagen damit bezahle ich jetzt.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es am Ende einfach ein Big Failure sein wird.
Ich glaube, dass er das Ding wirklich komplett ruinieren wird und irgendwann war es das dann.
Andererseits das schlimme ist, andere fühlen sich jetzt auch ermutigt,
ich glaube auch Facebook hat seine Policy bezüglich politischer Werbung wieder geändert,
also die Rechten sind schon stark dabei,
diese ganzen digitalen Netze ready zu machen für die nächste Wahl in den USA
und das wird noch spannend werden zu sehen, was dabei rauskommt.
Also auf jeden Fall der alte Traum, dass uns diese ganzen Entrepreneure da im
Tech-Sektor mit liberalen,
positiven Gedanken retten werden, ich glaub der ist ausgeträumt.
Also liberal in der positiven Konnotation, wie wir das ja haben,
aber es ist halt eigentlich eher die negative Konnotation, die ich zumindest
habe mit dem amerikanischen liberal Begriff, der ja sehr viel mehr so der Staat
soll sich raushalten und Bitcoin ist geil und so weiter beschäftigt.
Spaß. Das wird super.
Das ist alles so schade. Aber in Deutschland kannst du ja auch irgendwie mit
dieser Eiwanger, dieser Vollidiot.
Ich hätte den ja für ganz andere Sachen rausgeworfen, dass dieses Flugblatt
ist ja nur die Krönung. Da ist der gewählte Vizeministerpräsident von Bayern
erzählt, man müsste sich die Demokratie zurückholen.
Also da fragst du dich doch ernsthaft.
Ich verstehe nicht, wie man das, was wir da in den USA sehen,
in irgendeiner Weise als Vorbild sehen kann oder sagt, das ist eine positive
Entwicklung, auf die wir hinarbeiten wollen.
Dass da niemand sagt, wir müssen aus dieser Scheiße raus. Ich finde es zum Heulen.
Ja leider ist es bei den Konservativen so, dass sie einfach in ihrer Unfähigkeit
in irgendeiner Form mit richtigen Angeboten für die Gesellschaft populär zu werden,
halt einfach auf die Strategien der amerikanischen Rechten zurückgehen,
so nach dem Motto, ja guck mal hier man kann auch einfach die ganze Zeit Scheiße
erzählen und damit auch halbwegs erfolgreich sein.
Hauptsache wir schütten viel Öl ins Feuer und nähren die Medien mit Material,
die einfach für Spaltung in der Gesellschaft sorgt und dann werden wir diese
Spaltung schon irgendwie für uns zu nutzen wissen und das ist eigentlich das,
was so schlimm daran ist.
Das ist sehr gut beobachtet.
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch immer wieder Rückschläge. Wir haben jetzt hier nochmal
die Meldung zum Radio Dreieckland, ein fünftes, zwanzigstes Mal.
Ja, da ist jetzt festgestellt worden, die Durchsuchung bei Radio Dreieckland,
wir erinnern uns, das sind die, die in einem journalistischen Artikel über dieses
Indymedia-Links unten einen Link hatten auf die Archivseite davon.
Und auf dieser Archivseite hatten, wie Can Torkel hatte das ja kommentiert,
unter anderem irgendwie mehrere Landeskriminalämter und so auf Twitter ebenfalls verlinkt,
aber Radio Dreikland bei den Journalistinnen haben sie dann eine Hausdurchsuchung
gemacht und diese Hausdurchsuchung der Redaktionsräume wurde jetzt als nicht
verfassungsgemäß und nicht verhältnismäßig und damit als rechtswidrig abgeurteilt.
Aber das Strafverfahren, das läuft weiter, Also das ist der aktuelle Stand,
die unverhältnismäßige Durchsuchung, erhebliche einschüchternde Wirkung,
Verletzungen des Redaktionsgeheimnisses und so weiter, ja.
Hat das Landgericht alles anerkannt und damit gesagt, diese Durchsuchung war
einfach nicht rechtens.
Aber das Strafverfahren läuft jetzt erstmal weiter. Dieser absurde Fall wird
natürlich noch einige Zeit weitergehen.
Außerdem wehren sich jetzt endlich, oder was heißt endlich,
wie es zu erwarten war, Wir haben ja darüber gesprochen,
dass die letzte Generation zielstarker Überwachungs- und Ermittlungsmaßnahmen
war und unter anderem das Pressetelefon abgehört wurde,
wo man ähnlich wieder sagen kann,
naja, wenn du davon ausgehst, dass diese Gruppierung irgendwie kriminell ist
und verbotenes tut, dann werden die potenziell, sage ich mal,
das Pressetelefon abzuhören ist dann schon sehr weit.
Insgesamt haben sie 13 Anschlüsse abgehört, also offenbar auch die Privattelefone
von entscheidenden Personen aus dieser Gruppierung.
Und jetzt wehren sich die Journalistinnen, die bei diesem Pressetelefon angerufen haben,
und sagen hier, wir haben dort angerufen,
wir haben uns mit der Klimagruppe ausgetauscht in unserer Tätigkeit als Journalistin
und wir können natürlich nicht akzeptieren,
dass Journalistengespräche ununterbrochen monatelang abgehört werden,
die Abgehörten das nicht wissen.
Das ist ein Angriff auf die Pressefreiheit und deswegen gehen wir jetzt dagegen vor.
Finde ich auch in Ordnung und ist richtig.
Die waren also mehrere Journalistinnen zusammen mit Reporter ohne Grenzen und
der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte.
Und würde ich jetzt auch sagen, dass das nicht lange dauert,
bis auch diese Maßnahme als rechtswidrig abgeurteilt wird.
Und dann gibt es noch eine richtig schöne, also es gibt eine absolute Premiere, kann ich sagen.
Es gibt bei wenigen Seiten, weiß ich, bei wenigen journalistischen Seiten,
weiß ich, dass sie zum aller aller aller aller aller ersten Mal bei Logbuch
Netzpolitik verlinkt werden.
Du wolltest gerade ansprechen.
Und ich bin mir absolut sicher, dass wir zum ersten Mal auf die bunte als Primärquelle linken.
Die bunte.
Ja, da sind immer sehr unterhaltsame Sachen auch drauf. Also hier Royals ist
extra eine Kategorie für auch.
Ich gucke mir gerade hier mal aktuelle bunte Luxus Report
die Geheimcodes der Superreichen Natalia
Wörner und Heiko Maas lieb es aus die ganze bittere Wahrheit Angelina Jolie
zerbricht ihre Tochter am Scheidungskrieg Jörg von Tora zurück zur Ex-Freundin
ich wusste gar nicht, dass es Jörg von Tora noch gibt.
Ja, Karoline Beil Manche Menschen sind echte Kämpfer, die auch dann nicht aufgeben,
wenn die Lage schwierig wird. Besonders die Vertreter dreier Sternzeichen gehören dazu. Bist du dabei?
Welches Sternzeichen bist du denn?
Sag ich nicht.
Naja, also sagen wir mal, angenommen du wärst Widder oder Jungfrau oder Steinbock,
dann wär da was für dich dabei.
Dann klickst du doch sofort drauf.
Na dann kommt nächstes Mal.
Okay, was berichtet die Bunte?
Der Ex-BSI-Präsident Schönbohm fordert 100.000 Euro Schmerzensgeld vom ZDF für
die von ihm erlittene öffentliche Verarschung und damit auch daraus folgende,
Degradierung, die ja nicht finanziell degradiert ist, aber eben die Abberufung
als Präsident des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Und in der Show wurde Schönbrunn mit Clownsnase gezeigt und vom Böhmermann als
Cyberclown verspottet.
Da muss man zugeben, der Begriff Cyberclown wurde erstmals öffentlich vom Chaos Computer Club.
Verwendet und wurde dann da viel zitiert.
Ah, finde ich auf jeden Fall mal
ganz gut, wenn jetzt hier ein Clown gegen einen Clown vor Gericht geht.
Die ganze Geschichte um Schönwurm ist natürlich sehr viel größer und breiter
und das hatten wir aber hier alles schon besprochen.
Deswegen nur hier einmal Gruß an das Investigativ-Ressort der Bunden.
So, was war in Polen los?
Ja in Polen. Polen ist ja sehr engagiert unter anderem in der Unterstützung der Ukraine.
Und vor ein paar Tagen, konkret am 25. und 26.
August, sind auf einmal 20 Züge der polnischen Eisenbahn gestoppt worden.
Einfach so. Also auf freier Strecke, waren die so unterwegs und auf einmal wurde
Notbremse eingeleitet.
Gut sowas kann natürlich mal passieren.
Waren die alle in der gleichen Region oder waren die irgendwie über Polen verteilt?
Das kann ich dir nicht genau beantworten. Also ich würde jetzt mal gegeben die
Umstände sagen, das dürfte in etwa dasselbe Gebiet gewesen sein,
kann aber durchaus sein, dass da schon ein paar Kilometer dazwischen lag.
Auf jeden Fall sind 20 Züge einfach so gestoppt worden.
Und da fragt man sich natürlich, wie kann denn das sein?
Und schnell war davon die Rede, dass es sich hierbei um eine Cyberattacke handelte.
Cyber, Cyber, wir wissen ja.
Hacker, Netzwerke, komplizierte Systeme, Elektronik, Pipapo,
da sind richtig findige Leute am Werk.
Und es macht ja dann auch schnell den Eindruck, dass es hier einen russischen
Propaganda Hintergrund hat.
Man muss natürlich dazu sagen, das polnische Eisenbahnnetzwerk ist nicht ganz
unerheblich beteiligt an der Unterstützung der Ukraine,
weil natürlich da sehr viele militärische Lieferungen durchgeführt werden und
generell wissen wir natürlich auch um die Bedeutung eines Eisenbahnnetzwerks
für die Infrastruktur eines Landes.
Ist ja bei uns auch jetzt nicht so der Fall, dass das keine Rolle spielen würde.
Auch wenn jetzt so 20 Nothals innerhalb von zwei Tagen, das haben wir jetzt
in Deutschland noch nicht gesehen. Und das hat auch einen Grund.
Nämlich den, dass in Polen...
Noch ein etwas älterer technologischer Standard bei der Absicherung von Eisenbahnlinien vorherrscht.
Der Standard ist ja dieses ETCS, sozusagen das europäische Trainsystem,
wohin jetzt so Schritt für Schritt die gesamte Infrastruktur in Europa hin abgegradet wird.
Und in Deutschland haben wir ja für die Zugsteuerung schon seit längerem die
ganze Basis auf der Technik von GSM, GSM-R.
Wir hatten das neulich vor ein paar Sendungen schon mal, wo das ausgefallen ist.
Das ist natürlich auch eine kritische Infrastruktur, aber es hat zumindest den
Vorteil, dass sie so halbwegs grundverschlüsselt ist und von daher nicht so
ohne weiteres zu erseibern ist.
Aber in Polen ist es leider noch anders, denn dort sind noch einige Züge und
Strecken mit der ganz alten polnischen Technik unterwegs und dabei handelt es
sich leider um eine komplett unverschlüsselte und leider auch unauthentifizierte Technologie,
die darin besteht, dass du nur auf einer Trägerfrequenz von,
150 MHz ein paar Töne drauf modulierst.
Also drei verschiedene Frequenzen, die du nur jeweils 100 Millisekunden lang abspielen musst,
das macht also tututut und dann hast du mit diesen drei Tönen ein Signal ausgesendet
und wenn du so sagen wir mal in einer Reichweite von ein paar Kilometern bist
und ein Zug empfängt diese Töne,
dann wird sofort ein Nothalt ausgelöst und genau das ist dort,
hat dort stattgefunden.
Warum weiß man, dass da vermutlich Russen dahinter stecken, abgesehen davon,
dass die natürlich ein relativ großes Interesse haben dürften.
Abgesehen von diesen Tönen wurden dann auf dieser Frequenz auch noch die russischen
Nationalhymne abgespielt.
Das hat dann schon mal so einen gewissen Hinweis darauf geliefert,
wer hier ursächlich dabei ist.
Die gute Nachricht ist, bis 2025 möchte dann Polen auch die Umstellung auf GSMR
abgeschlossen haben, aber bis dahin müssen sie sich auf einiges einstellen.
Warum erwähne ich das jetzt? Naja, weil es wieder mal so ein Beispiel ist,
wo man so richtig das Bedrohungspotenzial bei der Anwendung von Technologie
von vornherein nicht gesehen hat.
Wir haben ja auch ähnliche Fehler bei uns im Telefonnetz,
wo sozusagen unser Telefon, ja also wenn wir Dienste in Anspruch nehmen wollen
von einem Mobilfunknetz,
Naja dann müssen wir ja hier SIM-Karte, Verschlüsselung,
Kundenidentifizierung, pipapo, was muss man nicht alles auf sich nehmen,
um in irgendeiner Form von dem Mobilfunknetz angenommen zu werden,
um dort Dienstleistungen in Anspruch nehmen zu dürfen.
Das Netz wiederum kann einfach nur sagen, ja ich bin dein Telekonnetz.
Glaub mir alles. Und die hier oft schon angesprochenen Techniken zum Abhören wie die IMSI Catcher,
die ja dann einfach mal sagen, ja ich bin's, dein Telefonnetz,
buch dich mal hier ein, aber es ist dann halt gar nicht das und das geht halt
so einfach, weil die Netze sich wiederum mir gegenüber nicht authentifizieren müssen.
Und so ist es hier leider auch bei diesem Zug-Emergency-Stop-System.
Und das ist natürlich eine dumme Sache. Und man könnte sich vorstellen,
dass die Polen unter Umständen ihren Technologie-Upgrade jetzt dann doch ein
bisschen noch beschleunigen sollten als bis 2024.
Ja, allerdings, also das Problem mit dem, ich kann sagen, ich bin dein Netz,
das hast du primär in GSM.
Also bei 3G, 4G, 5G wird es schon schwieriger, dass du einfach jemandem sagen
kannst, ich bin das Netz und das Telefon wird das einfach nehmen.
Aber das ist nur eine kleine Detailsache, weil du natürlich dafür sorgen kannst,
dass die Leute entsprechend downgraden. Also klappt's trotzdem.
Wir haben noch Jobs.
Einen. Einen haben wir noch.
Einen nur, schade.
Genau. Das jetzt für alle Systemadministratoren unter euch, die sich vielleicht
noch verbessern wollen.
Denn frag den Staat, sucht einen Systemadministrator.
Mit diversen Zahlen, hier steht 60 bis 100 Prozent, also man kann seine ganze
Arbeitszeit dort verbraten oder auch nur 60 Prozent und 24 bis 40 Stunden die Woche ab Oktober 23.
Und dann kann man sich für Frag den Staat einsetzen. Ja, vielleicht ist das
ja was für euch und der Link dafür ist in unseren Shownotes.
Die Grundlage von Frag den Staat ist Freude, eine Sammlung von Django-Apps,
die zusammen eine Informationsfreiheitsplattform ergeben.
Diese Sammlung wird in einem Django-Projekt genutzt, zusammen mit weiteren Apps,
die unser CMS, unseren Blog, unseren Newsletter und unser Spendensystem antreiben.
Wir nutzen ein per SCSS angepasstes Bootstrap 5 und dort, wo es sinnvoll ist,
nutzen wir im Frontend View Komponenten. Das ist alles, glaube ich, relativ zeitgemäß.
Ein NGINX-Server mit Unicorn liefert Frag den Staat und unseren Online-Tipps.
Onion-Dienst aus. Wir nutzen Postgres und Postgis als Datenbank.
Alles komplett beschrieben. Also das ist ja fertig.
Findet ihr alles in dem Link. Klicken, klicken. Ihr wisst ja schon, wonach es geht.
Genau. Link. Sagt, wo ihr es gefunden habt. Und dann haben wir noch Termine.
Musik Los geht es zeitnah mit den Datenspuren in Dresden im Zentralwerk.
Haben wir schon jedes Jahr glaube ich angekündigt, wenn sie stattgefunden haben, die Datenspuren.
Ein Event des Chaos Computer Club Dresden mit freiem Eintritt und sehr sehr schöner Atmosphäre.
Insofern das ist schon übernächstes Wochenende. Ist also wärmstens empfohlen
15. bis 17. September im Zentralwerk.
Genau und in Köln gibt es die Sono-J oder Sonoy Convention,
ich weiß gar nicht wie man das richtig ausspricht, ich sag mal Sono-J,
aber liegt wahrscheinlich falsch damit, bist du Musiker, Klangdesigner oder
Open Source Enthusiast, dann lade ich dich zur Sonoy Convention 2023 am 7.
Und 8. Oktober in Köln ein.
Netzwerke, Vorträge, Workshops, Live-Auftritte, Menschen mit deinem Interesse
freuen sich dich kennenzulernen, Eintritt frei, Spenden willkommen und man muss sich da auf sono.org,
registrieren, dann kann man dabei sein. Das ganze ist sozusagen der Hintergrund,
dass man eben hier Audio-Produktion mit Open Source-Technologien promotet.
Ja sieht auch ganz gut aus alles, ich hab keine Ahnung wie du jetzt darauf kommst,
dass das Sono J heißen soll, aber.
Wie würdest du denn das aussprechen? S-O-N-O-J.
S-O-Neu.
S-O-Neu-Convention. S-O-Neu.
So neu.
So notch. Weiß ich nicht, also nicht optimiert auf Aussprache.
Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendwas was man total wissen muss, ich guck mal ob die den FAQ.
Also wenn du schon einen Aussprache-Guide brauchst in deiner FAQ,
dann ist das mit dem Namen egal, wir kritisieren das jetzt nicht,
das ist halt einfach S-O-N-O-J. Punkt.
Org. Oh hier, what is the meaning of Sonoi?
Sonoi is Esperanto and means just sounds. Esperanto. Sonoi.
Das war mir Sonoi. Ja, wie spricht man es aus? Wie spricht man es denn aus?
Sonoi wahrscheinlich. Sonoi? Sonoi?
Weiß ich nicht. Das ist ja unklar.
Ich kann kein Esperanto.
Naja, ich auch nicht. Alles klar.
Okay, und dann, ich glaube da haben wir auch schon für, genau,
es gab einige Leute haben uns gefragt, was denn, wie man denn den schönen Song,
den Viktor beim Camp noch für uns gespielt hat, runterladen kann.
Ich glaube, habt ihr doch schon runtergeladen in unserem Podcast.
Offiziell released wurde der glaube ich noch gar nicht, aber man kann dem Solo-Projekt
Hitzefrei auf Mastodon folgen und Instagram haben wir auch verlinkt.
Und genau, das ist Viktor von Systemabsturz und Systemabsturz macht jetzt eine
längere Kreativpause noch nicht definierter länger.
Und in der Zeit macht Viktor alleine ein bisschen weiter und zwar mit diesem
Projekt Hitzefrei, was wir da hatten. Und am 27.
Oktober gibt es quasi das vorerst letzte Systemabsturz-Konzert.
Es wird das letzte Systemabsturz-Konzert für eine Weile sein,
deshalb fahren wir noch einmal alles auf, was wir so haben. tolle Gäste,
Überraschungen und so weiter. 27.
Oktober im Privatclub in Kreuzberg ist der, glaube ich. Berlin Kreuzberg.
Und da gibt es noch einige wenige Tickets, habe ich erfahren.
A. Genau. Link in den Shownotes, wie immer.
Gut, ich denke, damit haben wir den Teil dann auch abgearbeitet.
Und haben fast pünktlich es geschafft, diese Sendung zu Ende zu bringen.
Wir werden bald wieder wichtige Themen haben, so BND-Gesetz,
NIST-2-Umsetzungsgesetz, Kritis-Dach-Gesetz.
Das wird alles wieder richtig schön. Der Winter wird heiß.
Freut euch schon drauf.
Und ich glaube in der nächsten Sendung gehen wir auch nochmal auf Feedback ein
und wir werden jetzt generell,
wo unsere Urlaubszeiten langsam vorbei sind und die Politik sich auch wieder
langsam wiederbelebt, denke ich auch wieder sehr viel öfter podcasten hoffentlich, lieber Tim.
Genau also wir sagen tschüss und bis zur nächsten Sendung.
Bis dahin ciao ciao.